Palestinians have condemned an incursion
by Israel's security minister into the
Al-Aqsa mosque compound itama bengavir
caused outrage by declaring that Israel
owned Jerusalem the Palestinian
presidency has described the incident as
a flagrant attack while Hamas says it
highlights the serious threat facing the
holy site the Israeli government has
also been holding its weekly session at
an archaeological site near Al-Aqsa
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu said the location of that
cabinet meeting was a message to
Palestinian president Mahmoud Abbas and
a reminder of the importance of
Jerusalem to the Jewish people
56 years ago during the Six-Day War
Jerusalem United us but I am forced to
say that the battle for its unification
is not complete I and my colleagues are
forced time after time to fend off
International pressure from those who
want to redubide Jerusalem and also from
prime ministers in Israel who were ready
to surrender to this pressure to the
extent that they were ready to concede
the most sacred places for Jews but we
acted otherwise
from West Jerusalem Villa Marx hasmore
this was not the first time that as
minister of National Security in Israel
Ben gavir entered the Alexa compound and
it's been increasingly common for Ultra
nationalists inside Israel to visit the
mosque compound over recent months in a
move that many many Palestinians find
incredibly provocative the background to
this of course is a relatively recent
ending to intense fighting between the
Islamic Jihad group in Gaza and the
Israeli military and also the fact that
just days ago we had a march here in
Jerusalem that was intended as a
celebration but in recent years has
become far more of a provocation the
groups in Gaza the factions in Gaza both
Islamic Jihad and Hamas have condemned
the move the Palestinian president
Mahmoud Abbas has called it quote
unacceptable violation of international
law and the jordanians as custodians of
the site their foreign Ministry
releasing a statement talking about this
as something the International Community
needs to wake up to and work to try and
stop these activities these incursions
image digitally villain marks Al Jazeera
West Jerusalem